Ratsch mit Sauce mein
G detected
Die G mise ich ein
G
certificate
Preises
Fatische Mitwürste
Rain
Abbe前
Leute ich muss mal kurz was ausprobieren, weg, weg, kurz was ausprobieren, wir machen
jetzt huge huge animation pass mal auf massive animation hier
übermorgen ja keine abschlussprüfung das wird ohje ach das geht schon hast du
hast du prüfung hast du alte prüfung gemacht zur vorbereitung wenn ja dann ist das überhaupt
gar kein problem da würde ich mir mehr gedanken machen als um die abschlussprüfung
aber den ganzen tag wieder anstrengendes zeug gemacht habe ich mir gedacht bevor ich
jetzt pennen gehe mache ich noch mal eineinhalb stunden in streamern oder so ja ja alles in
ordnung war anstrengend morgen muss ich wieder nach frankfurt fahren zum arbeiten da habe ich
mal sowas von kein bock drauf aber einfach die woche ertrage ich ja noch irgendwie
lull easy lull wird gekauft techniker sage ich gleich was zu braucht paar sachen noch nicht
sicher was die ehrkeisen kacklern mein die prüfung sind im endeffekt so der ahnung so
nichtsagend und missverständlich das ist mein arsch
in frankfurt ich glaube das ist ein china laden in dem ich regelmäßig essen war glaube
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher frankfurt china lebensmittel vergiftung
nein ich glaube das ist ein china restaurateur ich zeige jetzt nicht von was ich glaube was es
ist ich glaube da war ich früher regelmäßig essen in dem restaurant
vielleicht musste ich deswegen auch schon paar mal kacken weiß es ja nicht aber 65
leute 65 leute ist schon hart wer weiß wie es an die küche ausgeschaut hat
glaube ich glaube ich weiß was es ist 32 g
32 gigabyte gibt es gibt es gibt es auch eine coole aussprache von gigabyte irgendwie
ich meine ubuntu spreng die coolen leute jubanto aus ich rede leise ich kann gar nicht so viel krach machen gigabyte
oder geeks geeks ist gut gibi bei könnte man noch machen weil die coolen leute ja jetzt explizit
explizit sagen 1024 gibi moment gibi beidt gibi beidt sagt kein mensch meine frage
irgendjemand auch gesagt er schreibt hier mark sag mal kommt das in der irka prüfung dran
möchte die möchte die irka die letzten jahre über den unterschied wissen zwischen
gibi beidt und und megabyte und sowas und dort wo es nicht dabei steht mit was soll man rechnen
mit 1000 oder mit 1024
weil normalerweise müsste man immer 1000 rechnen wenn da mega oder so steht weil es
steht da nicht mebi hast du eigentlich video oder pc spektakel ja habe ich das ist schon
alt weil ich seit dem kanal pc gekauft habe 2017 legendäre kameraarbeit hier
legendäre das ist immer noch der gleiche pc
gut ich meine ich habe mittlerweile noch ein bisschen mehr speicher drin aber da muss ich
mal überlegen der pc ist doch es hat sich minimal was geändert einmal 16 gigabyte ram
mehr dabei und noch deutlich mehr zusätzliche ssd speicher aber im prinzip ist es immer noch
das gleiche ich meine das muss man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen der pc ist von
ende 2017 und der pc wird jetzt bald fünf jahre alt alle fünf jahre
können euch das vorstellen leute das gab es noch nie das gab es doch nie dass du ein pc
455 jahre verwenden kannst und die sachen immer noch auf high spielst was ist das denn wo sind
wir denn wo sind wir gelandet früher konnte nach zwei an den pc wegschmeißen also ich weiß ich
weiß noch also eines eines meiner meiner einschneidenden erlebnisse damals war ich
hatte eigentlich ganz guten pc in atlon fragt mich nicht atlon was hat man damals so gehabt
atlon xp irgendwas so und dann kam kreises nähe nicht kreises schwachsinn nicht kreises
fahrkreu fahrkreu eins kam damals raus und ich habe das installiert hat mir gedacht ja
geil hier gib ihm all die geforce 3 geforce 3 grafikkarte war drin ja weiß ich noch geforce
3 dachte ich mir gib ihm das spiel lief nicht das ging einfach nicht und ich musste es am
ende fakt ich musste alles auf lau stellen alles auf lau außer außer textur auflösen die konnte
ich auf mittel stellen oder spielt er immer noch verhältnismäßig gut aus und es lief mit
gerade mal flüssigen 25 30 fps oder so und der pc war zum damaligen zeitpunkt nicht mal
ganz zwei jahre alt wann war denn das atlon xp was gab's denn da für welche 1900 gab's
da so was 1900 plus ich glaube so einer war das wann kam die raus release date ja genau das
waren die die ich nicht aussprechen konnte so brad release date release date release date
2002 alles klar das passt doch oder fahrkreu eins release date das ne leute ich sag's euch
nicht ganz zwei jahre mein pc und da ist nicht wirklich aber also das datum stimmt das bild
stimmt nicht so und ich kann mich einfach und auf diesem auf diesem stand bin ich hängen
geblieben irgendwie im kopf dass ich denke man bräuchte alle zwei jahre neuen pc dass
man neue sachen spielen kann die sache ist plus die wenn ich mir hier mein setup angucke
ssd ist immer noch absolut top kannst du nicht sagen mehr schneller brauchst du nicht cpu
ja gut wird jetzt nicht mehr in den benchmarks gerade in multithreaded benchmarks weit oben
sein aber gaming performance lass es mal leute was ist meine cp mein cp übrigens auch übertaktet
auf 5,2 gigahertz glaube ich mit mit flüssig metall kühlung mit dem mit dem der dauer der
dauer flüssig metall legierung was ist denn das gaming performance von der cpu 15 prozent
langsamer als aktuelle gute cpus vielleicht so viel hat sich das muss ich mal überlegen
ich das rate ich jetzt einfach ich weiß es nicht ich rate das jetzt mal keine weiß ich
nicht genau ich meine multi multi core performance ist natürlich scheiß da ab gegen aktuelle
zwölf kerner das ist klar aber games brauchen keine zwölf kerne und games brauchen sechs
kerne ok was weiß ich der ist 15 20 prozent langsamer als aktuelle cpus im gaming vielleicht
samuel danke für den sub also ist auch vollkommen in ordnung ram brauchst du auch nichts schnelleres
vollkommen in ordnung den ram kannst du heute eins zu eins immer noch so verbauen die grafikkarte
die geht theoretisch besser aber so viel langsamer als aktuelle high end grafikkarten ist die
auch nicht es ist jetzt nicht so dass eine 30 90 irgendwie doppelt so schnell wäre eine
30 90 ist keine ahnung 50 prozent 40 40 prozent schneller oder so also es hält sich es hält
sich echt in grenzen mainboard immer noch immer noch vollkommen in ordnung sogar 10
gigabit onboard netzbergkarte lüfter würde ich heute eins zu eins wieder so kaufen top
top lüfter recht hin besser lüfter gehäuse eins zu eins würde ich mir wieder so hinstellen
netzteil auch also lull also warum warum sollte ich mir neuen pc kaufen ich wollte mir schon
die letzten jahre über ich wollte mir bei der ersten bei der ersten ryzen generation
dachte mir jetzt ist aber so weit und dann war die cpu die ich haben wollte nicht lieferbar
dann habe ich mir gedacht bei der ryzen bei der zweiten ryzen generation bäm jetzt ist
es wieder so weit dann waren cpus und dann gpu ist nicht lieferbar ist ja jetzt immer
noch teilweise so so deswegen habe ich das jetzt immer weiter aufgeschrieben mit neuen
pc kaufen und gucke jetzt mit dieser kiste rum und ich kann alles was aktuell rauskommt
wunderbarst spielen überhaupt kein problem
ach ja was heute gekauft wird ich lese jetzt noch den chat durch ich brauche ein paar
sachen ich brauche einen wasserkocher fahr mal mit dem unspektakulären an ich brauche
noch einen access point ich brauche noch einen feuermelder ich will mir endlich mal die wetterstation
bestellen da hat mich ja der chat letztens auf den geschmack gebracht gucken wir mal
an hörst du auch musik oder eher so der radiotyp nein ich meine radiosignale würde ich mal
sagen du hörst gerne radio ich höre kein also ich habe beim essen manchmal radio an
und höre dofe werbung und regt mich drüber auf ich höre kein radio ich höre in der
regel entweder playlists also irgendwelche relaxing focus work playlists auf youtube
finde ich ganz gut oder ansonsten haben wir da eigentlich passendes bild für nicht so
wirklich ansonsten heavy metal beste
übrigens wer auch wer auch auf auf etwas etwas härteren steht wisst ihr was mein absolutes
lieblingsalbum der letzten jahre über war kann jetzt leider nicht anspielen aber wer
das noch nicht gehört hat und so ein bisschen auf power metal steht richtig geil das kam
vor zwei drei jahren raus oder ok ist schon ein bisschen älter
2015 ok mega geil ist eines der besten power metal in den letzten jahren die ich gehört
habe pock aber man muss auch so fantasy power metal stehen ist das glaube ich eher nicht
so das ja so man muss es umrechnen können bei der iak ok das ist gut das ist das ist
das größte problem was ich mit der iak prüfung hatte dass es nicht klar war was du machen
musstest und du teilweise antworten angekreuzt hast von denen du quasi so das gefühl hattest
dass die eigentlich fachlich gesehen falsch sind aber du musst sie ankreuzen weil die
akademisch wahrscheinlich hören möchte
was hältst du von wpf ich ich gebe zu meine cringe antwort wäre jetzt abstand aber ich
keine ahnung und wpf ich habe hier ein mega fettes wpf buch 1200 seiten irgendwo hatte
auf jeden fall mal eins ich weiß gar nicht wo es gerade steht mega fettes wpf buch hatte
ich mal und das hat ich muss jetzt gerade mal kurz nachgucken wie viele seiten das hat das
hat mich dann richtig abgeschreckt your orders glücklicherweise habe ich das alles bei amazon
amazon bestellt warum gibt es autocomplete auf dem handy wenn man amazon orders sucht
wpf ja das hatte ich mir damals gekauft windows presentation foundation das umfassende handbuch
amazon ok das ist irgendwie eine neue auflage hat seitenanzahl 1248 seiten das habe ich
mir damals gekauft weil ich ein bisschen mit wpf rum gebastelt habe und ich habe festgestellt
wpf gefällt mir nicht ich habe mich damals irgendwie durchge weiß ich so durchgekämpft
aber ich bin nie warm geworden mit wpf und im endeffekt weiß ich jetzt auch warum weil
wpf einfach nicht der style von framework ist der mir gefällt zum programmieren das
fängt schon an mit der xml geschichte für die oberfläche und geht weiter mit diesen
ganzen magic property binding geschichten wo keine sau versteht was genau an welcher stelle
passiert dann diese ganze sache mit or code behind ist böse du musst mvvm machen für
eine anwendung die nur zwei fenster hat und solche klaumens fragen jetzt mittlerweile weiß
ich was ich auf wpf abgeschreckt hat und ich mache immer noch einen großen bogen wpf leider
hat das microsoft bis heute nicht geschafft hat ordentlich zu ein framework rauszubringen
für windows mit video all drei hätten sie die chance gehabt ich weiß nicht wie es da
aktuell aussieht das haben sie ja immer wieder verschoben und verkackt ein bisschen zu spaßig
die musik gerade du hast windows als haus und lindungs virtualisiert so war es glaube
ich ja korrekt ich habe hier meine mit meiner liegungsform laufen die nicht die die ist die
ist nur wenn wenn weeps in angesagt ist die da hier fullscreen fullscreen kann ich rüber
switchen welche spieler so 2200 späße am meisten spielt das willst du nicht wissen
ich habe da ketchup kamelot auf einem freeshark gespielt zwar jetzt auch schon wieder ein
paar wochen nicht mehr wir haben sogar mal gestreamt aber da hatte ich bestimmt wieder
auch playtime von keiner ahnung viel zu vielen stunden ich habe das ich habe das seit release
drei monat am stück durchgekreinet jeden abend boomer spiel boomer games ja und das spiel
ist von 2003 oder so richtig bei meinem pc wurde ein bisschen ram abgekratet das war
es das ist richtig ich spiele auf 1080p das liegt aber auch daran weil ich mir ist es
lieber ich habe 240 fps als ich habe eine höhere auflösung das stimmt wenn ich auf
auf was ist die nächste höhere auflösung ist ja nicht 4k 1440p spielen würde oder gar
4k dann wird es natürlich anders aussehen ja gut das mache ich ja nicht mache ich
halt nicht leute jetzt wo du schreibst ich habe mir damals vor zig jahren habe ich mir
2 terabyte samsung ssd gekauft für 800 euro 2 terabyte heute heute kriegst du das für
200 und du kriegst eine vier terabyte für die hälfte aber das war noch keine nvme das
war eine sata die ich damals gekauft nvme gab es noch nicht samuel danke für den sub
gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile wie sieht es aus amazon müssen wir gleich hin gibt es
eigentlich mittlerweile erschwingliche 8 terabyte ssds und nicht kubo oder sowas weil kubo ist
das sack oder kubo was sagen denn die leute cute cute vor kubo ist der sack müll außer
man möchte bei einer ssd bei 150 mb die sekunde hängen gibt es anscheinend nicht gibt keine
8 terabyte ssds ja ja bei 4k aber auf 1080p glaube ich nicht dass die wirklich doppelt
so viel leistung hat ich hätte jetzt gedacht 40 prozent oder so aber gut ich habe das jetzt
die benchmark nicht so im kopf ja das weiß man bei der ihk meistens nicht da bin ich
auch da bin ich auch ich bin im juni bei allen meiden und im moment die power wolf ist vorgruppe
für allen meiden glaube ich an frankfurt sogar war das nicht so aber da bin ich auch
ich bin im november bei power wolf und ich bin im juni bei allen meiden in frankfurt
übrigens ich bin der übelste kacknup wer spricht englisch iron iron aus anstatt iron
niemand niemand sagt niemand in deutsch alle deutsche sprechen ist iron aus iron meiden
bei iron meiden aber da habe ich auch 15 jahre gebraucht mich da dran zu gewöhnen ja da bin
ich auch am start in der hoffnung dass das dann auch alles wieder funktioniert naja ganz
ehrlich für kleinscheiß finde ich wenn aus forms besser als wpf die moderneren features
die wpf hat reißen sie jetzt anders raus weil es ist trotzdem für alle das fack ja
also eigentlich hatte wpf jetzt wirklich nicht so viel auf windows forms gerade wenn du irgendwelche
irgendwelchen content rein rendern willst ist von open gl bis direkt x oder sonst was
in das fenster ist es mit windows forms deutlich einfacher ja die iak fragen sind mega für
ein arsch einige es haben schon viele im chat geschrieben hier iak abschlussprüfung wie
viel ram braucht die vm nicht naja die vm selbst hat glaube ich auch 16 g aber so viel
braucht das nette der vm habe ich 16 g gegeben sie meint aktuell zu jusen 5 und guckt mal
was windows meint wo sieht man das hier überhaupt gescheit processes war immer workstation
das läuft als gut das sehe ich hier gar nicht oder schauen wir mal prozess explorer als
gut öffnen schon ob da die ram auslastung lastung
200 kann eigentlich schlecht sein keine ahnung ja ja ja das spiel das sollte mal content bringen
und nicht nur content liegen ja das sind das sind aber magnet festplatten keine ssd es
ist nicht nur bei den china chinesen heute wir kaum wahrscheinlich zum größten teil
was bei amazon was liegt was was habe ich wieder geliegt achso achso battlefield das
ist wenn man im chat so weit hinterher ist ja das würde ich das haben wir auch schon
überlegt aber ich mag 240 fps 42 fps ist wenn ich mir einen neuen monitor kaufe dann
bleibe ich wahrscheinlich auch eher bei gibt es eigentlich 1440 p 360 fps gibt es sowas
rock swift ist das der monitor der ein lüfter braucht dass er kühlt bleibt geht sogar geht
sogar moment das ist er gar nicht gut jebaited
ja wie gesagt mittlerweile ist das kein ding aber der ssd brauche übrigens auch noch
klein meine projektdokumente iak vergessen also was vergessen verschlammt oder besser
gesagt die server ist gecrasht als meine projektdokumente hochgeladen habe dann haben sie gesagt ich
habe meine projektdokumente hochgeladen also habe ich mein video drüber aufgenommen
ich weiß nicht was ich da noch machen soll ich habe jetzt hier die kiste laufen mit unrate
weiß ich nicht was ich da noch großartig zu machen soll ich meine das ist halt vorhanden
und es funktioniert bald kommt die neue version raus habe ich gelesen bei denen auf der homepage
die sind jetzt schon bei release candidate hier oder fünf oder so
doch gleich noch mal einkauf einkaufsstelle hast du erst neulich den monitor gekauft dann
so lange ist es jetzt auch schon bisher thank you twitter hab den monitor ja komm schon
zwei jahr her wo ich den gekauft habe das ding ja zwei jahren habe ich mir das teil
gekauft so ein bisschen ja kann man schon was neues holen aber jetzt hole ich erst was
neues beim neuen pc und dazu brauchen wir neue cpus und neue grafikkarten vor allem
also wenn es eine 4090 gibt zu vielleicht nicht 5000 euro dann wird es wahrscheinlich
mal mit neuen pc bald mal wieder so weit sein hat jemand eine ahnung welche linux distribution
standard installation plus docker engine ist wohl die ressourcen sparsamste ram speicher
bereite gerade l pine linux würde ich sagen aber aber nur für docker images nicht ach
so ne ne du willst du willst das nicht als docker im image du willst das als zum zu benutzen
da nehmen ganz ehrlich das ist besser dass die leute den miss gescheit bedienen können
nehmen mind mit xfc oder eben weil die ganze nicht mit e3 kommen oder sowas oder ein aktuelles
ubuntu oder so das läuft ganz passabel in der vm auch mit mit größerem desktop also
ich würde mit ich würde mit xfc nehmen weil xfc in der vm besser läuft als gnome und
kde aber die leute dürften wahrscheinlich am besten klarkommen mit ja wahrscheinlich
mit mit irgendeinem linux mint oder so da kannst du nicht so viel verkehrt machen einmalig
koste das einmalig ernsthaft null und was haben sie gesagt sagen mal wie ist es wenn
man vpn und kann man sich unbedenklich bei youtube anmelden also genauso wenig oder genauso
viel wie vorher ich glaube ich weiß worauf du anspielst dass das vpn deine youtube daten
abgreifen könnte oder so meinst du das das kann eigentlich nicht passieren da du youtube
über htps also ssl bzw tls benutzt da kann dein vpn anbieter nichts machen muss halt
nur gucken dass das hier schön htps ist aber auf der anderen seite wenn du deine vpn anbieter
insoweit nicht traust frage ich mich warum verwendest du einen vpn anbieter also ich
würde ich würde vpn anbietern auch nicht trauen aber ich verwende auch keine vpn anbieter
also warum na gut wahrscheinlich ok ich rate jetzt einfach mal du lädst dir linux distributionen
und sicherheitskopien über torrent runter und möchtest dabei auf youtube surfen und
hast das vpn an wir wissen ja alle bescheid dass er sicherlich bloß linux distributionen
und sicherheitskopien über torrent runterlehnen premium aber aus indien premium aber aus indien
ist am einfachsten für mich zumindest über eine digital außen vm ich habe eine digital
außen vm in bengalore in indien und darüber mache ich ssh socks proxy und dann mit meinem
firefox in den indischen shop und youtube premium kaufen habe ich das tors alda weiß
gar nicht ob man das erzählen darf also ich mache das ja nur für bekannte nicht für
mich selbst klar unentgeltlich unentgeltlich ja
hat wer erfahrung mit den neuen nein null ich habe keine ahnung von den beiden neuen
ausbildungen das lustig mag dass die lehrer mein video kennen
ja ok verstehe ich dann dann leuchte es ein ja kann sich einloggen kann sich einloggen
also lang das hatte tps musste keine genannten machen dass das irgendjemand mitlesen kann
und ansonsten einfach zwei fakte identifizierung an um doppelt trippelt abgesichert zu sein
oder wie julian bam drei fakte identifizierung
was hältst du von krypto nix ich bin ja mit meinem world etf schon überfordert
der übrigens aktuell sehr not stonks nach unten geht
letzte deine linux isos von zu hause runter oder wie
ach so ja wie gesagt nur linux isos übers vpn und und über torrent
sagen wir mal ernsthaft ich habe legit über die letzten die letzten keine ahnung zehn
jahre oder so weder torrent verwendet noch irgendwelche komischen dubiosen seiten zum
downloaden von von sachen verwendet erstens für software ist es viel zu heikel dass ich
mir den virus einfangen und für filme und solche sachen stream ich mittlerweile was
das einzige wo ich über streams gucken würde ist wenn es das halt in deutschland nicht
gibt weil wieder irgendein studio oder irgendein vertrieb der meinung ist deutschland kommt
ein halbes jahr später oder nicht in originalsprache oder nicht das und nicht jenes wenn die mir
das nicht geben was ich gucken will wofür ich auch bezahlen will dann ist es wieder dann
ist es was anderes dann würde ich das machen aber war in letzter zeit nicht bei stimmt
nicht leute stimmt nicht am ist erzählt ich habe tatsächlich letztens ein zwölf folgen
anime geguckt über seiten dafür ja ja und nein ich weiß was ihr sagen wollt nicht sowas
sondern sowas ich wusste ich wusste das erste kommt wieder mit sowas um die eckes
war mir so klar alter antivirus nur den windows defender sonst nix ich glaube es ist noch
nicht mal verboten dass man youtube prämie über indien verwendet gut ich habe es geschafft
richtig genau wenn man zeit für season drei fand ich gut obwohl man sagen muss der hatte
durchaus seine perversen momente ja also ich habe gedacht mich erwartet da irgendwie so
eine 0815 fantasy story ja dann ging es teilweise doch etwas in die andere richtung ja macht
der label champ nix nix großartig nix großartig gut also jetzt geben wir amazon boah leute
ich muss mal kurz den dark wieder anmachen mein meine augen besser viel besser exquisite
man ist eigentlich mal wieder irgendetwas ein week black week dark week friday week monat
prime week cyber monday week season das muss jetzt das ist doch laufend irgendwas bei amazon
hat der chat schon wieder das heißt auch so heißt das nicht nicht black week black friday
week heißt das ja amazon kein dark mode ganz einfach weil boomer nicht den vorteil was
heißt boomer boomer und was ist denn der leute was ist denn der der entsprechende griff also
boomer und zoomer ist beim alter was ist denn bei der der der begriff für nicht technik
affine leute dau ist doof dass das trifft ja nicht so ganz noobs ja noobs kann man in
dem fall auch verwenden normies normies finde ich besser ja normies trifft es besser in
dem fall normies weil für normies weil für normies
alles klar weil für normies das teufelzeug ist dark mode die denken sich was wollen die
ganzen heckermanns da immer mit ihrem dark mode ich brauche light mode man muss aber
auch fairness halber sagen es gibt tatsächlich apps die sehen im light mode besser aus das
ist mir jetzt schon bei einigen ios apps aufgefallen dass die den dark mode irgendwie nicht so
richtig gebacken bekommen haben und da ist light mode tatsächlich optisch deutlich ansprechender
boomer ist für mich keine eilstellung kein alter das ist wohl wahr das ist wohl wahr
weil es gibt ja auch keine genaue definition zum thema boomer boomer sagen die leute irgendwie
wenn sie sich Gedanken darüber machen ja das sind jetzt quasi die die baby boomer generation
also die die jetzt irgendwie keine ahnung 60 plus sind oder so was ja wiederum überhaupt
nicht trifft weil im internet ist ja im prinzip schon jeder 30 plus eigentlich boomer und
auf der anderen seite finde ich das mit dass es einstellung eigentlich viel heffener du
hast sicherlich 15 jährige boomer von der einstellung und du hast bestimmt 55 jährige
zoomer ich meine natürlich verschiebt sich das immer weiter ja also potenziell sind
natürlich viel mehr zoomer jüngere leute um boomer umgedreht immer ältere leute aber
es gibt in allen altersgruppen bei solche und solche was verwendest du für ein mikro
und für ein interface also ich verwende jetzt was anderes als für meine videos wobei das
interface ist immer das gleiche das ist als audio interface das hier das habe ich auch
schon seit 2011 oder so alt habe ich schon lange gar nicht weil das rausgekommen ist
daran erkennt man das immer ganz ganz gut release date das hatte noch feierweih er neben
usb leute könnt euch das vorstellen feierweih er das kennt auch keiner mehr feierweih
weiß ich wann das rausgekommen ist ja also das habe ich als audio interface aber für
meinen für meine videos dann nehme ich ein normales mikrofon was ich auf den tisch stellen
kann und jetzt hier im stream habe ich ein mx 300 etzer mit dem mikrofon ich habe übrigens
gelesen dass demnächst ein neues kommen soll irgendwo weiß ich wo ich das gelesen habe
auf reddit irgendwo oder so da muss ich die mal beschwätzen sagen gibt mir eins und sponsort
mich und ich mache massiv sehr laut alles klar ok also pick auf sponsort gürtelstraße
louis vitor store zahlen die kollektion bar pick auf sponsort so ging das das ist übrigens
wer das nicht kennt das ist haftbefehl pick auf sponsort weiß nicht aus welchem dann mit
pump gun alles klar ja massiv massiv lyrics gürtelstraße gürtelstraße louis vitor store
zahlen die kollektion bar pick auf sponsort alles klar jetzt haben wir uns auch weiter
gebildet mit massiv frankfurter offenbacher muss man ja sagen offenbacher lyrics sowas
was ist was ist monka monka tost hier dran der text oder was ja cringe ich habe gehört
haftbefehl hat sich letzten selbst ins bein geschossen also im wörtlichen sinne nicht
im nicht im übertragenen sinne gestern hat der youtube algoritmus wieder durch den gartenstelz
im schnee vorgeschlagen ja ich meine muss ich mal vorstellen aus irgendwelchen gründen
war youtube der meinung dieses video 2 millionen views alter ich weiß nicht was mit youtube
los ist alter 2 millionen views von der fucking baustelle im garten oh man da hat sich das
youtube da hat sich youtube algoritmus gedacht wo welche nice video das muss ich promoten
den software musste durch da musste durch das war ich so leute ich müsste mich eigentlich
noch rasieren fällt mir gerade auf der morgen wieder nach frankfurt fahren
erwarte rausholen nö ich brauche kein rasierer zu bestellen das mache ich morgen früh
ja ist eine richtig gute erfindung für alles wo du nicht anderweitig das smart bekommst
ansonsten sind andere varianten wenn möglich besser aber manchmal hilft es nur den knopf
zu drücken dafür sind zwitschpots gut meinung zu svelte habe ich mich doch schon öfters
geäußert finde ich richtig pock pocke finde ich das pogu haben wir das emote überhaupt
noch sekunde pogu ja haben wir noch richtig pogu wie streng ist bei euch die kleine ordnung
es kommt drauf an wo du bist also oder ja wo du bist und was du bist also wenn du bei
uns im außendienst tätig bist dann ist eigentlich so gut wie immer anzugpflicht aber das ist
ja normal aus außendienst stellts wenn du auf irgendwelchen außendienst schulungsveranstaltungen
unterwegs bist dann wird das dir immer sehr nahegelegt einen anzug oder zu irgendwie zumindest
ordentlich anzuziehen wobei war da auch schon hat ganz normal jeans und und t-shirt pulli
oder hemd an hat auch keinen interessiert ansonsten ist bei uns keine kleine ordnung
es schwebt unseren managern manchmal vor sowas zu etablieren wie eine kleine ordnung
ich weiß noch irgendwann ist mal einer mit flip flops durchs treppenhaus gesprindet bei
uns und zwei tage später hing dann in den in den aushang im treppenhaus dass man irgendwie
auf wie haben sie es wie haben sie es umschrieben irgendwie arbeitsplatz bezogene bekleidung
achten soll oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung aber es gibt keine kleine ordnung ich hätte
auch keinen bock irgendwo hinzugehen mit anzug
pogo gibt es hier pogo fand ich auch immer blöd pogo habe ich nur eingefügt weil es
der chain law haben wollte wenn ich mich richtig erinnere also ich habe manchmal kurze hosen
an nicht wirklich baseballschott wenn es wirklich warm ist habe ich kurze hosen an das hieß
mal eine zeit lang so nach dem motto das kann man ja nicht bringen kurze hose auf der
arbeit aber ganz ehrlich wenn es die sommer die werden immer wärmer und die letzten sommer
waren richtig ätzend heiß da waren wir teilweise an die 40 grad in frankfurt ich bin am mittag
zum südbahnhof gelaufen das war innen drin erträglich ganz dank klimaanlage aber ansonsten
trotzdem warm esfack und wenn du jeans an hattest du konntest ja gar nicht raus bist
ja du bist direkt gemeldet da hatte ich kurze hosen an und ansonsten ansonsten habe ich die
kurze hose jetzt im rucksack die ziehe ich mir dann halt mittags an wenn ich heim gehe
wenn es warm ist dann einfach so aber kommen wir mal zu amazon ich muss noch kurz meine
meine einkaufsliste aufmachen wird fast fangen wir an wollen wir wirklich mit dem wasserkocher
anfangen das war nicht gelogen das war nicht gelogen leute eines der teile ich brauche
tatsächlich ein wasserkocher die anderen sachen dürften aber deutlich interessanter sein aber
wir fangen mit dem wasserkocher an was ist ein guter wasserkocher wasserkocher
ok russl und hops wisst ihr wie sich das anhört wie ein fast and furious film heißt das nicht
sogar so fast and furious russl hops hops und schor ok fast fast ganz ehrlich das ist auch
eine filmreihe wo ich nicht verstehe warum es die eigentlich immer noch gibt mir komplett
unbegreiflich ich habe den ersten teil geguckt hat mir so gedacht ja ok ich glaube ich habe
insgesamt da noch ein zwei teile geguckt habe jedes mal gedacht ja jetzt haben sie gar keine
idee mehr was sie machen sollen und mittlerweile sind wir bei was von dem teil fast and furious
i 10 oder so das ist echt nicht mehr normal und es gucken immer noch leute was den dritten
wasserkocher den da ja den finde ich gut der bestseller den hole ich mir weil ich glaube
ich habe aktuell den vorgänger davon und der vorgänger ist kaputt der vorgänger hat
ein loch im deck hat ein loch im deckel und geht manchmal nicht an also rastet nicht ein
sondern blub blub blub blub braun wk 300 ja wirklich leute die wasserkocher empfehlen
können das ist pog der ist aber ganz schön schäpp oder warum ist er so schäpp zu warm
geworden bei der bei der herstellung als kräuse verzogen das ist natürlich krasses
design dass das wasser nicht so tropft da war der designer hat sich gedacht wir sind
richtig high iq als beim design also ich kann mir so richtig vorstellen der designer hat
da gesessen hat das ding entworfen als gedacht wir müssen noch irgendwas machen damit es
cooler aussieht und dann wisst ihr was der typ gemacht hat ich versuche euch das mal
kurz zu zeigen ich guckt euch das an und ich zeige euch was der typ gemacht hat der designer
hat sein design programm der designer hat sein design programm genommen und hat dann
hier so sein sein sein wasserkocher gemalt und hat dann hat dann hier irgendwann gesagt
ah ups moment convert to curves so und hat dann hier so sein wasserkocher gemacht so so
und und dann war er fertig und da hat er sich gedacht moment für den wasserkocher da brauchen
wir doch irgendwas und dann ist er in sein design programm gegangen hat so gemacht und
dann hat er gesagt jawoll das ist es so so jetzt kommt es raus das wird er diese genauso
mit der design prozess gewesen sein das braucht noch was agiles trendiges und hat er einfach
an eine ecke gezogen in seinem design programm und dann war es gut ok das ist nichts also
ich ich bestell mir den hier dass ich habe den gleichen den habe ich mir vor 10 11 12
jahren gekauft und er geht jetzt langsam kaputt wenn der hier jetzt auch 11 jahre hält 10
jahre hält dann bin ich zufrieden mit alles in ordnung das kommen jetzt wasserkocher
ist gut beim add in basket was haben was habe ich noch das ist so bescheuert warum will
mir amazon immer irgendwie so komische versicherung aufschwätzen ich brauch doch keine versicherung
für mein wasserkocher und es ist wahrscheinlich keine versicherung für mein wasserkocher
falls der wasserkocher brennt und das haus abfackelt das ist eine versicherung wenn es
kaputt geht der triple a energieverbrauch bei einem wasserkocher stelle ich mir generell
schwierig vor weil ich mein ein wasserkocher ist der inbegriff von energieverschwendung
also du benutzt strom um zu heizen aber es ist mag nicht irgendwie soll ich effektiv
sein aber oder f doch effektiv effektiv sieht ja aber es ist schnell wobei wenn ich mir
mittlerweile die gaspreise angucke ist es wahrscheinlich fast billiger damit die wohnung zu heizen
ich habe ja zwei klimaanlagen also ich habe im schlafzimmer und hier im arbeitszimmer
klimaanlage habe eine klimaanlage aber zwei geräte innen also die hängen am gleichen
aus dem gerät ja und die können auch heizen und ich bin mir ernsthaft überlegen ob wenn
es kalt werden sollte und die gaspreise weiter so steigen dass es nächstes jahr dann mega
teuer wird dass ich dann einfach heize mit dem strom von der klimaanlage was habe ich
denn hier sonst noch drin der fluxer der mini fluxer den habe ich schon den brauche ich
nicht das brauche das habe ich ganz vergessen das brauche ich tatsächlich das brauche
ich tatsächlich aber ich hole mir kein set mehr es sei denn es gibt ein set mit nur zwei
und mit nur dreier und und hier die großen brauche ich eigentlich nicht hier gibt es
gar nicht ich glaube es gibt nur kleine mittlere und ganz große brauche ich nicht ist egal
die ssd brauche ich auch nicht die 5a brauche ich nämlich so gut wie nie 5a habe ich noch
jede menge ich brauche zwei und drei also dreier brauche ich vor allem dreier brauche
ich das original war viel besser viel besser als das china chinesen ding das ist china
chinesen box mit wago dingern das hier ist mit original wago box jawoll aber ganz schön
teuer was ist da alles drin moment aber ich dachte es ist ein sortiment wobei das ist ein
sortiment oder wie viele 100 oder habe ich aber was zu tun 100 ist ordentlich ich bin
kein elektriker also so oft brauche ich den ach da sind auch solche dinge drin die brauche
ich nicht ich bin kein elektriker ich habe ich ich brauche zwar ab und zu mal welche
für bassline aber nicht so mega viele ne das ist das ist schon bisschen overkill hier
die brauche ich auch nicht mal lass mal überlegen was ist denn der unterschied die gelben sind
die für starre kabel wo man nur reinschieben kann ohne klipse das weiß ich und was sind
die was sind die die roten und die weißen die weißen sind auch nur zum stecken anscheinend
das hier sind die mit dieser federklemme aber also von den gelben habe ich auch eine box
aber was machen die roten nur die farbe die farbe ist für den querschnitt achso das ist
natürlich gut da weißt du gleich was du nehmen musst also wenn du elektriker bist ich brauche
selten nicht sachen die wo ich nicht die die die klemmen die die fehler den dafür verwenden
kann naja gut dann dann kein kein vago sortiment also wasserkocher wasserkocher ist vorbei leute
ich muss euch mal was erzählen ich lieb euch ja aktuell mit ein paar anderen access points
aktuell habe ich bei mir daheim und das ist eigentlich viel zu viel aber es geht nicht
anders weil ich wie gesagt ich bin mit unify sache nicht zufrieden aktuell habe ich ein
unify uap pro im erdgeschoss ich habe ein ap lite im keller ich habe ein nano hd im
ersten stock und ich habe ein wifi 6 access point ganz auf der anderen seite vom haus
richtung hof so tp link mit open vrt ja open vrt ist nice allerdings für meinen zweck
in dem fall diesem einfall nichts zu gebrauchen so ich bin mit dem unify unify zeug aber wirklich
nicht zufrieden ich habe verbindungs abbrüsse ab abbrüsse was ist abrisse oder abbrüche
jetzt war es jetzt max schon das neueste soll merkel video gesehen nee wieso was hat
er denn was hat er gemacht oder was hat er sehenswertes rausgehauen ist access point nur
ein cooler name für repeater nee access point ist was was was anderes ein repeater leitet
ja plus sachen weiter die schon da sind und an access point ist das was ursprünglich die
ssid aufmacht also der access point ist das was das wlan aufmacht ja danach da schiel
ich nehme ich auch gerade drauf ja genau und ich bin mit dem unify zeug nicht zufrieden
weil ich habe verbindungs abbrüche das schiebe ich nicht auf die verbindung weil die access
point sind ziemlich nah dran ich habe alles gut eingestellt keine überlappenden channels
ich habe die leiste runter gedreht dass die sich nicht so sehr überschneiden zumindest
bei denen die quasi im stockwerk in den stockwerken mehr oder weniger übereinander sind ich habe
eigentlich alles gemacht was ich machen kann um das unify zeug gescheit zum funktionieren
zu bringen und es funktioniert ja auch halbwegs es ist nicht so dass ich kein wlan empfangen
ich habe jetzt dafür dass ich einen hier am fenster stehen habe richtung terrasse ich
kann den garten gehen hab da wlan empfangen das ist alles in ordnung aber ich habe verbindungsabbrüche
und warum unify an sich gefällt mir auch nicht die controller oberfläche die hat zwar coole
funktion ja dass du dir die kleines auflisten kannst und sonst was aber dieses du machst
ein wlan an ein wlan ausnahm provisions erste mal 40 sekunden über alle access points die
kleines verbinden sie kleines verbinden sich random zu zig anderen access points weil die
zu unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten wieder hochkommen es ist also ich weiß nicht ich bin von dem
controller kein großartiger fan aber ich meine es funktioniert alles da an sich an sich würde
ich lassen ja ich habe ja auch da schon prinzip viel zu viel geld für ausgegeben aber unify
sind die ubiquiti dinger genau aber ein feature fehlt mir bei unify oder bei den ubiquiti access
point access points und das sind private keys pro device also also pre-shared keys pre-shared
keys pro device also wenn man sich zum beispiel mit einem esp oder wlan wlan led wlan klübirn
ergibt kein sinn led lampe leuchtmittel sagt man ja dazu mit wlan lampe verbinden will
und man schmeißt die irgendwann weg dann liegt die lampe mit deinem wlan password im müll
warum kein radius ganz einfach weil die ganzen iot gerät gerät zu 99 prozent kein radius
können das ist das ist das ist ein 1 a fehlendes iot feature was du heute eigentlich brauchst
wenn du viel iot geräte hast die dinger können so gut wie kein normales wlan gerät kann
und wpa enterprise so und dieses feature hätte ich gerne dass man quasi wie ich sag es jetzt
mal auf deutsch dass man wlan password pro gerät einstellen kann und dieses feature
hat fast jeder anbieter wir reden jetzt nicht von irgendwie asus tp link netgear so die
einsteiger consumer dinger auf auf amazon oder so aber ansonsten die bisschen höherpreisigen
haben das alle sogar mikrotik hat es und mikrotik sind relativ günstig aber ich bin kein großer
fan der mikrotik access point ich mag mikrotik router und switch aber access point nicht
so sehr zertifikatsanmeldung bring mal der wlan lampe zertifikatsanmeldung am access
point bei versucht es bei dem china china chinesen hersteller beizubringen du möchtest
private private dings wie heißt klein zertifikate machen auf deinem auf deinem iot gerät versucht
das mal dem china chinesen hersteller zu verklickern das wird nichts auf deinen eigenen geräten
vielleicht auf vielleicht auch auf deinen tablets und notebooks aber nicht auf irgendwelchen
microcontroller iot dinger obwohl der esp 32 der kann wohl wpa enterprise mit radios
aber tp link kann dieses feature nicht ansonsten ist es vollkommen in ordnung ok und worauf
ich gerade ein bisschen schiele sind diese dinger hier nicht ruckus ruckus oder ruckus
wie die coolen leute sagen und die haben nämlich gerade vor noch nicht allzu langer zeit eine
neue generation an access point rausgebracht access points rausgebracht und übrigens mal
nur so zum vergleich was sie was die kosten ja neu das wollt ihr nicht wissen also so
ein unify zum beispiel unify nano hd zum beispiel die kosten so 176 euro für die meisten leute
die denken sich 176 euro für den access point ist schon ganz schön viel wenn so ein billiger
tp link access point kostet 30 euro aber wenn man sich mal so so ein hier anguckt zum beispiel
da reden wir von ganz anderen preisregionen ja wobei das gar nicht der aktuelle ist ich
glaube aktuell ist der oder 650 aktuell bin mir gar nicht sicher ob der ob der aktuell
ist jeder 750 ist da eins größere access points also ich weiß gar nicht wo ich bei
denen auf der seite überhaupt danach suchen muss man solutions wo zum teuer sind auch
access points alda erbsenraube moin wo wlan ich check es überhaupt nicht ich gucke jetzt
einfach auf den ihrer home page wo der access point ist ja der 650 ist der aktuelle so und
die dinger sind halt teuer as fuck aber die sind richtig nice was die features angeht
und nachdem die erst vor kurzem quasi die access points gewechselt haben sind die leute
jetzt gerade auf ebay teilweise am raushauen von ihren access points und ich habe mir überlegt
ob ich mir nicht einfach so einen r 610 oder irgendwie sowas bestelle auf ebay falls es
die günstig gibt gucken wir mal ne aruba bringt mir nix weil ich bin mir jetzt grad nicht
sicher ob das die waren mit cloud management pflicht ne das waren die sysco dinger die
die sysco instant dinger glaube ich mit cloud management pflicht ne genau aruba bringt
mir nix weil aruba dieses private key pro device nur in verbindung mit clear pass hat
und clear pass ist irgendwie so eine extra security appliance sache von aruba und das
passt nicht ja also das das passt nicht ich habe mir das im vorfeld schon ein bisschen
angeguckt und ich bin aktuell tatsächlich am drauf schielen ob man nicht irgendwie
einen findet so und wenn wenn hier mal irgendwie einer guck mal das hier zum beispiel das ist
natürlich nicht verkehrt aber 535 euro ist mir trotzdem ein bisschen viel
fünf tage ne da biete ich nicht fünf tage da braucht es ja ewig bis das durch ist
ich meine das würde ich ausgeben aber am ende ist da wahrscheinlich auch mal 400 euro
weil wie gesagt neu kostet 1200 was bietet ein access point wlan wifi ebay kleiner sowas
ist wahrscheinlich eh nix für ebay wollen wir mal was letzte preis gucken komm wir gucken
mal was letzte preis sowas haben die da bestimmt nicht stimmt es gibt ja auch ein motorrad
was letzte ein euro das ist doch bestimmt jebait wenn du dahin fährst steht der schläger
krupp um die ecke und nimmt dich aus oder so das ist doch jebait
achja man muss gucken dass es die eu variante ist ist es die eu variante wo ist das wo ist
die modellnummer sieht irgendjemand die modellnummer hier drauf ip liegt leute nein das ist nicht
die modellnummer hier ww0 das ist die richtige das das ist die richtige man muss gucken dass
man nicht die us variante verwendet weil die us variante musste erst umständlich die die
us land umstellen offiziell darfst du es ja gar nicht oder kannst du es ja nicht so warum
bitte schön ein euro sie können sich gerne im hinteren film was
der neue was was der was er neu kostet gerne können sie mir einen preisvorschlag unterbrechen
wieso ich dachte ein euro jebait den schreib wahrscheinlich leute ebay kleiner zeigen wahrscheinlich
schreibst du den typ ich habe keine ebay kleiner zeigen keine ahnung wahrscheinlich
schreibt man den an und sagt ja keine ahnung 200 euro wie sieht es aus und dann sagt der
null guckt oder in dem moment die sagen ich null das sind ja keine twitch kucker die sagen
dann digga neu kostet 1200 oder sowas es ist schon 21 uhr 45 es ist schon 21 uhr 45
mann das ist eigentlich viel zu spät oder kann ich gar nichts mehr großartig jetzt muss
man so beeilen also da schiel ich so drauf was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten das sind
alle ohne support das lohnt sich nicht der 320 ich hätte gern ich hätte gern ein von
der 600 oder zumindest der 500er serie mit 3 an mit 203 empfangsdingern 17 stunden das
wäre was was ich mir durchaus gefallen lassen würde im renew bereich wo gibts das wo muss
ich gucken ich batte noch nie taugen die google und amazon mesh wlan dinger nichts keine ahnung
hier ausprobiert ich tippe aber eher auf ne also zumindest nicht wenn man die features
haben will die ich haben will ich weiß nicht ob die für einfaches rein stöpseln und mit
tablets ins wlan nicht reichen aber die können garantiert nicht alles was ich an features
haben will was soll ich suchen seil oder so hallo was ist los topics unleashed würde ich
dann drauf machen stand alone image ich werde einfach mal ein access point achso du kannst
die unterschiedlich ich das war keine das war keine frage weil es weiß du willst wissen
wie man das macht es gibt zwei varianten bei denen eigentlich gibt es eigentlich gibt es
drei varianten bei denen du kannst es mit unleashed flaschen unleashed ist komplett stand alone
beziehungsweise p2p controller das ist einmal die möglichkeit von unleashed flascht das
nächste ist die haben auch noch controller und ich glaube die controller bei denen nennen
sich smart zone und und zone control oder irgendwie sowas aber das will ich nicht das
brauche ich nicht ich werde keine ahnung ohne scheiß dort ich werde meine unify access points
einfach da lassen wo sie sind abstöpseln und dann nehme ich mal einen von diesen extra
points hängen sie in die mitte bei mir oben erster stok in flur und dann mal gucken wie
die abdeckung ist ach ja übrigens auch ein weiteres cooles feature was diese dinger schon
seit seit jahren haben die haben antennen die sich von dem wie die abstrahlen so wie nennt
man das polarisieren können ich weiß nicht wie man das genau nennt in beim wlan also
die die strahlen quasi die signale in die richtung das ausrichten genau die die strahlen
quasi die signale in die richtung des clients aus für den die sachen bestimmt sind was
ziemlich gute technik ist es ist auch was was was unify nicht hat ne nicht beamforming
beamforming ist die die die die allgemeine sache die haben noch irgendein die haben irgendein
spezielles beamforming die haben irgendwas die haben irgendwas eigenes noch mal was angeblich
noch besser beamflex genau beamflex heißt bei denen da wahrscheinlich ist es auch so
was nur ein bisschen proprietärer knempel ja also den würde ich mir geben allerdings
für ein euro wird er mir den wahrscheinlich nicht überlassen vermute ich mal so wie sieht
es denn aus gibt es da zum beispiel 710 oder sowas ich suche jetzt mal ein paar access points
durch dass man nope nope fünf tage leute da biete ich nicht drauf das dauert ewig kann
man nicht hier irgendwie einstellen sofort kauf doch sofort kauf 1000 euro ich glaube
es geht los
das sind alles die dinger die haben alles kein support mehr das brauche ich nicht naja
ich meine 350 euro ist durchaus auch ok wenn man das us-variante in die us-variante bringt
mir nix ich habe kein bock irgendwie das zu anlocken naja us-variante geht theoretisch
schon weil man kann es gibt wohl die möglichkeit country unlock ich muss bei den gar nichts
lizenzieren das ist ja das gute da dran ich hoffe den access point flash unleashed drauf
und gut ist also ich habe bei github gefunden man kann wohl denn man kann wohl über kommando
zeile den access point umstellen auf eu von us wenn man das will oder muss man muss es
ja machen wobei ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher bin ob da krempel überhaupt funktioniert
dazu finde ich nichts und ich habe halt keinen bock mir für 350 euro an access point zu kaufen
auf gut glück und dann festzustellen mist ich kann den kram nicht um umflaschen oder
um updates gibt's ja ja das muss man flaschen von denen das ist das stand alone für die
access points das nicht die richtige seite ja ja gibt es gibt auf ebay.com ja das ist
das ist us ja und mit import und allem ist das gleich gleich teuer das ist halt die us-variante
ich meine man könnte es mal ausprobieren mal gucken gibt es gibt es vielleicht was
anderes gibt er der r600 ist mir eigentlich eine nummer zu zu alt schon der hat nämlich
beispielsweise als auch nur us egal wie auch immer das das gucke ich mir mal ohne euch
an muss jetzt ja nicht sein dazu macht der zoll bestimmt auge das geht über ebay international
shipping wahrscheinlich my ebay wo stellt man bei ebay seine kann man bei ebay ohne
sich einzuloggen die ziel adresse einstellen gibt das irgendwie dass man so flawless nix
ist flawless keiner ist wieder los der 320 ist mir ja ich hätte am liebsten ein mit
drei antennen also irgendeinen irgendeinen oder zumindest zwei wie der 500er am liebsten
hätte ich ganz ehrlich am liebsten hätte ich irgendwie preisleistungsmäßig in r6 110
oder so die sind zwar noch nicht mit wifi 6 aber scheiß drauf ganz ehrlich wenn das
ding ordentlich funktioniert brauche ich kein wifi 6 aber aber halt ein mit wave 2 oder
so wie die das nennen wäre schon ein verkehr aber us ich bin mir gar nicht sicher wie das
ich copy paste mir das jetzt mal guck mal was ebay meint wenn ich bei ebay deutschland
nachher rein haue was das kostet mit versand und dann kann ich mal nichts probieren um zu
flaschen der 320 der hat das jetzt weiß ich ja aber der 600 der normaler r600 hat das
nicht ich muss mal gucken was ich bekomme ja aber da liebäugel ich ein bisschen mit
wollte ich eigentlich bloß mal zeigen vielleicht biete ich auch einfach mal auf die anderen
müssen wir mal schauen so ich brauche noch ganz wichtig da habe ich nicht vergessen
und zwar ich brauche noch einen fürs wohnzimmer ich bin nämlich aufgefallen ich habe ich
habe feuer melder eben also haben wir hier im stream gebaut wir haben hier im stream
gebaut den empfänger smart smart home anbindung wobei rauch melder heißt ja eigentlich korrekt
er 850 habt ihr im einsatz ja die sache ist plus die wenn die anderen nicht schon teuer
waren guckt euch mal was ein r was ein r wenn er 850 kostet das ist ein fucking access point
für 2000 euro man nee nee nee nee nee leute naja aber ich brauche fürs wohnzimmer noch
ein ich weiß schon welchen ich brauche rauch melder ich brauche ein ei das war jetzt sehr
unglücklicher satz aber ich brauche ein ei 650 rf da habe ich nämlich überall anders
auch mir ist aufgefallen ich habe ich habe im arbeitszimmer ein ich habe im flur ein
ich habe unten im flur ein ich habe unten im schlafzimmer ein ich habe oben im schlafzimmer
ein was mir aufgefallen ist ich habe im wohnzimmer kein was ziemlich bescheuert ist weil im wohnzimmer
steht so viel technik sollte mal wirklich irgendwas brennen da könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass es eventuell sogar im wohnzimmer anfängt die haben preislich zugelegt die haben preislich
zugelegt ich habe letztens erst noch vier stück bestellt für ok 70 euro hack wait
bist du dir sicher dass du vor einem jahr den gekauft hast mit funk modul dabei und integriert
er zehn jahres batterie die normalen kosten 25 euro naja ob häuser jetzt im endeffekt
brennen oder nicht ist das kleinere problem die innen einrechnung kann aber auf jeden
fall brennen ohne funk modul aber mit batterie ja die sind deutlich günstiger das funk modul
ist das alter chat wer von euch hat mein browser gerade gehackament ach das ist hier dark reader
dark reader spackt wiederum ja da brauche ich ein von basket da brauche ich ein von
ich habe noch kurzzeit aber wetterstation ssd und so was machen wir machen wir machen
wir morgen kommt funk modul durch den guten gewölbekeller ja ja würde ich schon sagen
ja also ich kann es dir natürlich nicht versprechen oder ich hafte nicht dafür aber das denke
ich schon das ist jetzt die rauchmelder bilden ja auch quasi auch ein mesh also wenn einer
den empfang also wenn einer rauch meldet und ein anderer ist in empfangsreichweite
dann leitet er das weiter bis zur basis station dass du dann auch dir eine push message schicken
lassen kannst wenn es brennt oder sowas und wenn einer anfängt zu piepsten fangen alle
an zu piepsten also kriegst du auf jeden fall mit wobei man das verhalten glaube ich ein
bisschen umstellen kann aber das müsste ich mir mal genauer angucken aber ich will das
haben also wenn einer anfängt zu piepsten sollen an alle anfangen zu piepsten ne ne
mit sich die rauchmelder ist es tatsächlich nicht so nicht so einfach die sind richtig
gut die dinger deswegen habe ich mir die auch gekauft gebe ich als 70 euro für aus für
zehn jahre kann ich das machen ist kein problem ich muss jetzt mal kurz chat schnell überscrollen
windows keys ist windows keys ein thema richtig weil iot nicht geht ich dachte linus hat unify
aber kann auch sein dass er auch mittlerweile festgestellt hat weil er ist ja auch nicht
blöd dass er auch wenn er komische sachen manchmal macht aber ich glaube zum größten
teile linus macht die sachen aus aus show effect
was windows keys ist das thema zeigt mal her ebay kleiner zeigen was neuste was letzte
preis jaja irgendwas mit windows keys billige windows key 1000 verfahren laufen boar 16
minuten
ja ich habe in letzter zeit kein windows key gekauft
also open wrt war übrigens auch meine erste idee dass ich meine wlan features bekomme
die sache ist plus die dass open wrt lustigerweise zwar den support dafür eingebaut hat für
quasi wlan passwörter pro gerät aber die haben noch keinerlei management support dafür
also kannst du nicht im webinterface einstellen oder auch anderweitig gescheit konfigurieren
was ziemlich doof ist weil ich möchte ehrlich gesagt nicht irgendwelche passwörter mac adressen
sonst was von hand in der text datei eintragen müssen dafür dass das dann am ende funktioniert
ansonsten ist wrt natürlich pock wobei es mir deutlich lieber wäre ich würde irgendeinen
günstigen ruckus access point kriegen auf ebay so siehts aus
never sub never donated adblock on stolen laptop neighbors wifi mamas haus stolen solar
paddels stolen solar energy stolen waterwheel neighbor rivers stolen was so ok das ist die
längste variante dieses copypastas die ich je gesehen hab normalerweise ist er nach 5
dinger ist das nicht heute eigentlich schon grenzwertig rassistisch dieser copypasta da
wird sich doch bestimmt irgendjemand gedriggert fühlen wieder
wenn du aktueller hatten wir schon tweed ist raus ich hab's nicht gepostet wenn tweed
ist raus ist und ich und dann werdet nicht ich sondern der chat wird gecancelt da muss
ich euch alle bannen
ob ich irgendwas überlesen was wichtig war chat bevor ich oft gehe es steht noch einiges
auf der einkaufsliste das war ja morgen weiter ich bin heute zu spät angekommen kennst du
das tool in tangi iris aber wie gesagt ich brauch keine lizenzen ich kaufe das ding
flash an an liege drauf und hat sich auslizenziert ja die gibt's der zoll macht generell wenn
du sachen aus den usa bestellt viel zu oft auge ich hab noch nie aus den usa und es kam
ist jedes mal als ich bisher was ich hab noch nicht so oft drei vier mal oder so aber jedes
mal als ich was aus den usa bestellt hab zoll jedes mal und einmal musste ich dem typ vom
zoll erklären dass ich kein fernseh bestellt habe sondern eine led leiste für den fernseh
er hat es nicht verstanden da habe ich gesagt das ist doch so klein wie soll das sein fernseh
sei der wollte der wollte wahrscheinlich hat in seiner liste fernseh mehr zollgebühren
gebracht oder so ja usa bisher immer über einem zoll gelandet immer ausnahmslos und
in china noch nie nest mag ich nicht ich hab die ich ich hab die diese 650f rauchmelder
und ich hab ein funkmodul von denen und daran habe ich das haben wir übrigens auch hier
gemacht im stream daran habe ich rauchmelder ist ist der rauchmelder stream nicht ah der
rauchmelder stream ist nicht im archiv weil ich irgendwas geleakt habe oder so glaube
ich wahrscheinlich ach nee das war der stream mit voterfond problemen oder oder habe ich
was geleakt ich weiß es nicht mehr gibt es nicht mehr ja leider haben wir diesen stream
nicht mehr beides kann sein wir hatten ein stream in letzter zeit mit heftigen voterfond
problem ich glaube das war der rauchmelder stream von wann ne ne lade den nicht hoch wenn
es den nicht gibt hat es bestimmt seinen grund und dann wird er nicht hochgeladen es hat
seinen grund wenn ich streams lösche im nachhinein entweder weil sie abgehackt waren empfangsprobleme
hatten zum größten teil oder ich vielleicht irgendwas gezeigt habe was ich nicht zeigen
wollte ja aber ich lösche die dinge manchmal nachher wenn irgendwas nicht passt also wenn
was in so großem ausmaßen nicht passt dass ich nicht im wort haben will von wann ich
weiß nicht wann der war er hieß irgendwas mit rauchmelder im titel kann ich mich trauen
das aufzumachen also 30 trillionen 50 billionen und die können wir mit unterschieden passen
von unterschieden ne nicht wirklich mecks also ja es ist es ist meck basiert weil ihr
irgendwo dran müssen sie festmachen aber du musst die mecks bin ich mir gar nicht sicher
ob du die hinterlegen musst doch ich glaube du musst moment unleashed es kann ich zeige
euch mal den screenshot nicht mpsk wie heißt der kram deal dpsk war den der heißt überall
anders sei krempel dpsk genau hier sieht man das setting nach geilen high res screenshot
ja hier dpsk heißt es bei denen wobei ich nicht weiß ob das das unleashed interface
ist glaube nicht das ist nicht das unleashed interface aber so ungefähr funktioniert das
ja und dann kannst du verschiedene passwörter für unterschiedliche geräte hinterlegen
was sehr praktisch ist wenn du nämlich dann ein iot gerät weg schmeißt kannst du dann
einfach in einem router das rausschmeißen und auch wenn irgendjemand das password davon
auslesen sollte kann er sich nicht mehr in wlan einloggen mir geht es nicht so sehr darum
dass ich sage das ist sonderlich wahrscheinlich dass irgendjemand meinen müll ausräumt mein
wlan passwort vom gerät extra hier es ist ehrlich gesagt sogar sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich
aber ich finde es blöd dass es überhaupt möglich ist also mich wurmt so sachen die
bei design irgendwie nicht nicht schön designed sind und gerade weil ich so viele iot geräte
haben fände ich halt nice wenn ich iot geräte hätte die ein einweg password pro kleint
also nicht einweg password ein einzel password pro kleint hätten soll ich snaps oder flat
hub verwenden oder am liebsten gar nichts davon ach so du musst unter ubuntu kann ich was
oder ubuntu ist neb doch eh schon drauf dann im dann im snap store wenn es dir anders geht
ja kann sein doch deswegen habe ich den gelöscht das
war der stream wo ich fünf mal kacken musste wo ich irgendwie was schlechtes gegessen hat
mittags oder so doch das war der das war der kack der kacke stream war das ich erinnere
mich wieder der kacke stream war das kackchamp alles klar leute
wir machen einfach wir kaufen einfach morgen weiter ein hat doch nicht so ganz geklappt
ich habe auch nicht mal viel zeit ich muss morgen auch früh aufstehen früh so früh
wie früher also früher bin ich 45 45 aufgestanden das mache ich nicht mehr ganz normal 7 uhr
30 oder so morgen aber zweiten teil leute wir sehen uns vielleicht mal gucken ob irgendjemand
online ist der kleine so dass ich haus brauchen kann dem ich folge semper video ist da den
haben wir das letzte mal schon also eine letzte mal schon gehostet in diesem video nur ganz
kurz keck weh echt ja den können wir hosten er hat mich das letzte mal gehostet das kann
man machen das mache ich was macht er denn was macht er denn zeigt mal her macht er denn
proxmox hacker mann content er verzweifelt auch an iot das ist doch schön da war doch
ähnliche probleme ok gut rate und ich shadow legends dieser kanal bietet chat nur für
folger oder ab follower oder abonnenten an naja egal machen was er wollte also wir sehen
uns leute im nächsten stream machts gut bis denn